hello everyone and welcome to pi data
global 2021. i would like now to welcome
eo casino with us welcome to pi data
global l and he is going to talk to us
about uh start to start asking your data
why a gentle introduction to causal
inference
hi good morning everyone from london i'm
ayal i'm a senior data scientist in a
health company and um yeah i was in a
similar situation last year when i was
at pi data global and i was wondering
how and if i should be learning about
causal inference so i'm very glad today
to discuss uh my learnings and the way i
approached it is i did some research i
formed with my colleagues a study group
and together we learned the topic and
the outcome was i feel that now i'm
better both in how i analyze data and
how i do experimentation and that's
something i talk about a lot uh with
people and i feel that if you say
something for a third time you might as
well write a blog post about it if you
say it for sixth time you might as well
submit a top proposal just before i
start i want to mention that all the
opinions are my own and if you're
interested in following the talk then
you'll have all the slides available
here just with this link
um all right so we put a lot of trust in
data we put so much trust in data and
such that we feed it to non-sentient
beings to um analyze it find patterns
make suggestions upon which you make
decisions of course i'm referring to
machine the powerful machine learning
processes that we're all beneficiaries
of but what i do feel is that there's an
overlooked question how much trust
should we put on data on its own
as a researcher my experience shows me
that i never trust my predictive models
until i do a full exploratory and i
understand my data and that's one of the
findings that i had from learning from
the god
judah pearl who's considered the
godfather of cause interference is that
causal interference derives from
understanding the story behind the data
and appreciating that that it's as
important as the data itself and that's
the main takeaway from today more
takeaways that
that you'll have is that by
understanding the portions of the story
behind the data you'll be able to avoid
misinterpretation of
an analysis
in addition to that you'll learn about a
very powerful yet simple to understand
tool called graph models which will
enable you to visualize the story behind
the data and that's what most of the
audience will take away from today for
those who are really interested in
taking it one step further i'll provide
resources that i found useful in my
journey into learning the topic
and um this this talk is not only for
the technical it's for anybody who makes
data driven decisions and is interested
in going beyond correlations and to
cause and effects in adding cause and
effect into their analysis and there's
no much requirements uh required maybe
high school statistics but very visual
oriented i've been doing data analysis
for uh and predictive model for over 15
years on various types of
data sets to name a few in cosmology
biology and now health care and what i
found found odd is that or rather
limiting is that as homo sapiens we have
been improving and developing ourselves
using causal cause and effect in our
everyday intuition but for some reason
um historically speaking as analysts we
haven't been doing that and
it's time that we start should
and so the way we're going to learn
about this is we're going to climb jude
apparel's causal ladder and the way i
structured it is through an agenda in
which i'll present the problem of being
in this current bottom rung and i mean
by that i mean what's the why what um
when we do correlation analysis why is
that limiting and we'll talk about that
also in this next part um
in which we'll discuss
um how we might be able to misinterpret
our data so through something called
simpson's paradox we'll
identify it we'll resolve for it and by
that we'll be climbing up to the second
rung
in addition i'll present this grab the
graph model tool in which you'll be able
to visualize the story behind the data
and then we'll summarize um how how much
you climbed up the ladder and what other
what other steps you should do in order
to further progress your understanding
uh i haven't said the word python yet i
will demo uh show two very short demos
using both streamlit and uh png
pgm pi
in addition to the slide deck you'll
have
links to all these demos so you can play
around with and grab me for a chat later
correlation does not imply causation you
know that phrase but why what does that
mean um and
how is it limiting and so what we'll see
in the next few slides is that by
limiting your analysis to correlations
you might be either
inconclusive or even worth worse get
you'll get misleading conclusions
i'm going to demonstrate this through a
few um
made up but plausible experiments or
scenarios
in this first one you'll see uh let's
imagine that a city council wants to
reduce the rate of drownings at their
beaches and so to that extent they want
to know how to optimize lifeguarding
duty so let's
uh let's assume that they don't know how
to do that and they want to feed all the
city data that they have available to um
to a machine so we can tell them how
should they base their scheduling and so
the machine it doesn't understand
context it goes through all the data and
then what it finds is that
a very important parameter is ice cream
sales why is that important because it
sees here that there's a very strong
correlation which we can visually see
but does that mean causation well we
know that most likely not right if there
isn't a shipment for ice cream let's say
there's a problem in the delivery that's
highly unlikely to change the drowning
rates so how do we overcome this well
what we know what we actually know is
that um there is a there is a common
cause which is the weather and without
that we have that spurious correlation
that we saw before but when adding that
component and accounting for that story
behind the data we can see that looking
on sunny days there's no correlation and
on chilly days there's no correlation
either
and so by understanding common causes
we'll be able to resolve for spurious
correlations of course that was a very
simplistic graph
in
reality is more nuanced than that and so
for example on this side you'll want to
understand supply and demand and on this
side well of course you want to
introduce the intervention variable the
treatment variable
which is related to the drownings and
everything that leads up to that
um so that's the first example another
example is let's say we want uh uh we
think of an engineer who wants to
improve in a lot a fire alarm system
what sort of experimental data should
they be collecting well of course they
want the fire temperature and the
distance from the alarm but actually
that's uh that's a good start but um
there's more to that actually there's no
such thing as a fire alarm the the alarm
is detected by the smoke and the smoke
is considered a mediator variable and
that serves as a proxy for the fire
imagine for example that we're
ventilating some smoke out of a window
and uh then there won't be any alarm by
the sound alternatively if there's no
fire but there's only smoke then the
sound will go off so in addition to the
fire variables you also want like to
measure the density of carbon monoxide
sticking with the
theme of smoke but now in regards to
cigarettes well now we know that
smoking cigarettes will enhance your
risk for lung cancer right we see that
labels in in cigarettes but we didn't
know this back in the 1950s back then
you had researchers find correlations
between the two but they were inclusive
about
what they could determine based on that
and what kind of decisions could be made
so for example tobacco industry they
could come up with a story behind the
data and saying hey maybe this is also a
sports correlation due to genetics
causing both increase for appetite for
smoking and risk for lung cancer an
alternative story is that maybe lung
cancer is impacted by both but there's
no real way to disentangle between them
because dna sequencing was not possible
until the year 2000
so how it was actually
resolved for was identifying a mediator
variable in the form of tar in the lungs
assuming that it isn't generated by
one's genetics then it's impacted by
smoking which in turn that's what causes
the lung cancer
and so what we talked about so far is by
limiting yourself to correlations you
have um you might be um inconclusiveness
in your analysis but even worse you
might actually be misinterpreting your
results and that's a very dangerous
place to be so it's and it's such an
important topic that i'm actually going
to dedicate the next topic to it
simpson's paradox and
as a disclaimer uh i'm going to use an
imaginary but plausible example data
and for simplicity we're going to assume
that it's statistically significant
another disclaimer is i'm going to do
something that may be considered highly
foolish as a presenter in the sense that
i'm going to confuse anywhere between 95
percent to 100 percent of the audience
uh but the reason that i feel that it's
worthwhile um and note that i'm going to
do this for 10 minutes about 10 minutes
the reason it's worthwhile is that
there's a huge lesson to learn here and
it will be memorable um hopefully it
will be enjoyable but the main reason
i'm doing this is because you might be
misinterpreted misinterpreting your data
right now when you're not aware and so
we'll we'll do this through an example
of a made up pharma study in which
they're looking into
measuring the benefit of a drug that
drug that they're developing so they set
up a random controls trial and what i
mean by that is that they have sick
patients that are equally distributed
amongst a control group and a treatment
and looking at the results we can see
the treatment group um recovered 58
percent of the time but that's less than
the control group so we see this gap
over here
and that's all fine but now let's take
let's um
look at actually cohorts at different
subsets so we look by gender and then we
see something interesting we see that
males actually the treatment recovers
and with an absolute 10
higher uh than the control and the
females have the same absolute 10
percent also we see that the females
recover um in both cases more than the
males so the same data but oddly we have
contradicting conclusions and that's
what the simpsons paradox is it's when
you have a contradiction between the
result of your population to your
subpopulations in the following slides
we'll see that this is isn't actually a
contradiction or a paradox but it's
rather misinterpretation and so we'll uh
so so now let's look at deeper in the in
the numbers and that what we understand
what are we actually missing what are we
misinterpreting here so here i'm just
summarizing what i said before the the
contradiction conclusions by focusing on
the population at large and at the
cohorts and here i'm presenting also the
numbers of the cohorts so here you can
see the 50 versus 40 and 90 versus 80.
i'm a big fan of visualizations and so
any relativisation that shows those
contrasts is very useful so here i'm
doing the treatment minus control where
the population is minus 14 and the
cohort is at um plus 10.
uh i love this uh this other visual that
really brings this home it was um
designed by mark flax he's a data
scientist that i met in pi data global
of last year and so i'm borrowing this
idea from him in which what he does very
nicely is how he separates between the
different groupings so first of all he
separates between the control and the
treatment group the horizontal axis is
the recovery rate and the vertical axis
is the number of participants
and then you can identify the control
group for example there's two two
different groups in which one recovers
an eighty percent rate and they're
actually eighty percent of the control
and then the remaining twenty percent of
control uh recovered at a forty percent
rate and so their mean is this red line
and that's the what we call recovery
rate of the control group uh and we do
similar thing for the treatment and this
is where the minus 14
is right treatment minus control
but the beauty of this visualization is
now we'll focus on the cohorts now we're
color code for them and now you can see
the females you you see the plus 10 here
and the same thing for the males same
data but different approach so what's
what's the truth um should we go by the
population or the cohort well that
depends again on the story behind the
data the story behind the data here is
that
both the outcome of the group
both the outcome and the group placebo
or drug depends on gender where gender
is an independent variable and hence
it's what we call a confounding variable
and what we should do is we should
control for that
and that's something that we haven't
done over here so this renders this
outcome actually is meaningless and to
be meaningful we have to control for
that and just to highlight the fact that
the gender is the confounding factor
those with hawk eyes noticed that males
were 20 of the population and females
were 80
okay so in order to adjust
for this uh for the confounder first we
have to be a bit more rigorous in how we
determine our metrics so when i say
treatment minus control that's what we
call the risk difference uh we're just
mathematically we write with conditional
probabilities it's the difference
between the recovery rate of the two
groups the treatment minus control and
these are the uh risk differences that
we saw for each of the
population and the cohorts so what we
have to do in practice is we have to do
weight adjustment so what we do is we
create this meaningful average causal
effect metric which what it does it
takes the weighted mean of the risk
differences of the different strata and
by that i mean the male and the female
assuming the weights are 50
per the group uh and so then you get the
result you expect the 10
uh and here's just the visual again this
is meaningless and these are meaningful
i just as i said before um you're most
likely to be confused that's fine i
shall demonstrate this to experienced
analysts and data scientists and all of
us get confused i'll be the first to
admit to admit it took me weekends to
fully understand and appreciate this
playing with
numerous examples on a jupiter notebook
and with time i found what was useful
for myself is a web app that i use
streamlit for and so you have it
available here if you want to play
around with it but i'll just show a
quick demo
um
yeah and so here actually the same
example in which i just coded up so you
have all the data you have the visuals
um and here's the flats uh figure and um
yeah so what i like to do is let's
in order to understand these things i
change the variables around so uh what
we'll do here is we'll look at one of
these cohorts and let's say that the
data was different let's say that there
was no impact for one of the genders and
so that's what i'm changing over here
and so here you can see that now they're
aligned and um so that means the impact
for the males is zero with the females i
didn't change anything that still is 10
over here uh and so this is a
meaningless metrics to minus 16. so we
want to calculate the ace so i'll give
you like two or three seconds think
between zero and ten what should the ace
yield right so that's what we expect
from an average person average male uh
male or female well if you guessed five
percent well that's correct right that's
the main between zero and ten so that's
just one of many examples that one can
try to use to play around with in order
to internalize to understand
simpson's paradox another way to
understand it is through this uh this
sort of visual in which uh the
equivalent of simpson's paradox using
continuous variables is lord's paradox
so what do i mean by that instead of the
drug and placebo binary variable imagine
you have medicine in milligrams and
instead of recovered or sick imagine
like a continuous health score so if you
don't have any cohort data then for
example you can see like a 20
correlation here and you can draw this
red line but if you add the story behind
the data like the cohort information
you'll see actually that you will learn
actually that adding uh medicine in
milligrams is deleterious in the outcome
for men boys girls and females
and so
yeah so i appreciate that's a lot to
take in and it's fine to be confused at
this stage
what should you take home from the
simpsons paradox well the main takeaway
is that anytime you identify that you
have a contradiction between the result
of a population
to its cohorts
the reason that's important is that if
you have that case if you have a
scenario
you have to be very careful not to
misinterpret the data and get wrong
conclusions
what should you do you should identify
the control the confounding factors and
control for them for those who are
interested in taking causal inference
the next step i highly recommend
mastering simpson's paradox
so we're actually going to continue on
this note of controlling for confounding
factors because that's a big part of
causal inference and the reason that's
important to highlight is the fact that
sometimes you'll hear how researchers
talk about uh a shopping list of many um
parameters that they're controlling for
but you have to be critical about this
and ask yourself the question is that
justified and that's a very hard
question to answer for and um
what you want to do is actually
introduce something called graph models
which helps you visualize the story
behind the data and then you make more
educated decisions about how to um
to decide which parameters to control
for and that brings us to the next step
um uh within in in the causal um in the
causal ladder in which we'll uh use the
graphs to visualize the story behind the
data and um judah correctly says that
this is the um
um that it's the missing vocabulary in
order to articulate causal inference
which is missing from most statistics
textbooks so we'll talk about this and
it's actually
in addition to being a very powerful
tool it's actually a very simple one
it's so simple that you actually know
what it is because when i talked about
let's say the smoke detector i actually
used graph models there and by the
arrows you understood um what was going
on but here i'll be more formal in
introducing it so what we do is that
each variable is a node and any two
nodes that are connected there will be
um
sorry any two nodes that have a
correlation will have an edge between
them
to add causality we turn an edge into an
arrow and which tells us which node is
listening to which
um
and just before here you can see for
example a and b are independent c
depends on on b and d and d depends on
all of them whether you have a slick
fraction uh cyclic um
interaction with c an even more simple
graph is called a dag in which uh the
essence of it is that starting from one
parameter you can never find the cycle
to go back to it for example you start
from a there's no a flow of information
that goes back to a
uh and the reason this is useful is to
be able to help you describe how the
data was collected and
put you can write down your your your
understanding of which parameter causes
which who listens to who and the reason
this is powerful is that you'll be able
to design both better experiments and
have better uh interpretation you'll be
able to make causal conclusions from
your data
and so we'll actually go back to the
simpsons paradox and it's it's it's very
simple to understand actually with the
graph model so this is the setup that we
had from before in which you'll notice
gender is independent outcome depends
both on gender and group and the reason
that the paradox arises is because of
this is because our treatment variable
the group depends on gender how do we
resolve it well we do what's called
graph surgery and what we do is we cut
off we eliminate this arrow how can this
be done can be done in two fashions
either we account for the confounding
factor in the randomized control trial
in advance that is a mine that's both
expensive but it also can be um in some
situations impossible here we're talking
for simplicity about only one
confounding factor which you have
might have many more and so the beauty
of what causal inference is that we can
apply it
the same concept to um observation
what's called observational data that's
something that's much more accessible
and much more cheap for example we
talked about the average causal effect
um the ace and so that's the same thing
in which we
[Music]
yeah we did the graph surgery there uh
we we we we adjusted for the gender
uh critics and
critics of causal uh um interference
correctly point out about subjectivity
right we're building a narrative behind
the data so that's having added
subjectivity as a data analysis analyst
um
my experience is that as objective as
i'd like to be i always have to make
subjective decisions at certain stages
and the challenge is to make sure
they're sound and reasonable
for example if you have a distribution
with two modes well you don't want to
naively take the mean or the median but
you want to understand the story behind
those modes um
and in the same regard yes in the graph
model you're going to make assumptions
but the beautiful thing that beyond the
scope of this talk but what you learn in
causal interference is that you'll be
able to empirically test the graph in
certain regions for
for
the
causal relationships between the nodes
by identifying the dependencies between
the parameters
causal inference is not always possible
it requires uh many assumptions um
it's beyond the scope of this talk to go
through them but um my understanding is
that the most important important one is
called ignorability and that's
the and what that means is um is dealing
with all the confounding factors and
that's why i make i'm putting an
emphasis on this uh for example we
looked at the drowning rates example
before this was what's called
in terms of a graph model it's something
called a fork situation in which without
so here we're confounding for z but
without that we saw that we have a
sporius correlation and that's what we
wanted to resolve for um
alternatively there's another graph
model that's called an inverted fork
in which we have something called the
collider and actually it's the opposite
than before it's beyond the scope of
this talk also but it's interesting to
point out that by
confounding for the
um
for this variable you're actually going
to generate spurious correlation between
the variables and so if you're
interested that my slide deck is
available and here i show a nice example
of a light and two switches uh in which
if you um if you adjust if you control
for the light you'll uh cause a sphere's
correlation between otherwise
independent switches uh so just to
summarize the essence of causal
inference depends on your ability to
control or not for uh parameters we
talked about common causes in forks
before i talked about mediators in
chains right remember smoke and tar in
lungs and beyond the scope of this talk
is colliders and something called an
instrumental variable
yeah so we're nearly at the end let's
see how far we went in our journey of
climbing up the causal ladder uh and so
we started by uh identifying the fact
that by limiting ourselves to
correlations we're taking a very passive
approach and the worry behind that is
that we might run into misinterpretation
for example spurious uh
spurious correlations or simpsons
paradox we observed the uh we resolve
the synthesis paradox by doing something
that now i'll call as do algebra what we
did in prod and what you saw in practice
here uh one flavor of that is we
controlled for a confounding factor
right the c um
in the in a manner called ace the
average causal effect and the reason
this is powerful is we can now do causal
interference for sub populations and
reflect that on the population at large
for example looking at a drug seeing if
it's beneficial for example for female
between ages 35 and 45 but even more
powerful is going to the third rung in
which what you'll be able to do is to do
it for an individual person so your
mother your sister or your cousin and
that's by means of something called
counterfactuals and which i don't have
time to talk about today but generally
speaking it's setting up hypothetical
conditioning uh in asking what if
statements what if the condition was a
bit different what would be the impact
of that so that's very powerful but as i
said before it's not always applicable
really depends on circumstance for
example if you have simulated data it's
much more likely that you'll be able to
do it with most real what real world
data you'll have the challenge of not
being able to rerun real-life scenarios
and so that means a lot more assumptions
are required but regardless my learning
state that what you want to do is um
is in any situation evaluate the
applicability of causal interference in
that way you'll be better both in how
you decide for experiments and analyze
it to further motivate uh the nobel
prize for economics went recently to
researchers that
help further develop understanding of
causal interference um so yeah so what
should you take away home with you to
share with your partner your friends
your colleagues is the fact that when
you have data you don't want to trust it
on its own but you rather want to
understand the story behind it how is it
collected what's the causal relationship
between the parameters that way you'll
avoid misinterpretation of the data
i introduced the graphic models as easy
to understand yet powerful tool to
visualize the story behind the data
those who want to take it to the next
step they'll be able to i suggest master
simpson's paradox then do algebra
counterfactuals um that that's the way
it works for me online who's giving a
talk for later in the conference he'll
talk about actually counter factual him
and i we're um we're aggregating
resources that we find useful uh and
here i'm just highlighting a few of them
for the layman i suggest the book of why
by jude apparel for the study group that
i mentioned before we actually used
his primary book that's very useful with
my remaining time i want to just just
highlight something about pgmp which i
found useful for the reason is that
they're using do operations
and so
what i have publicly available i made a
notebook in which you can actually go
through my simpsons paradox example
right over here in which you'll be able
to
learn how to generate the story behind
the data to calculate things like ace
like the ace parameter so i want to i
want to thank my colleague james baker
who is a true doodle master who created
his visualizations i want to thank
streamlit all the stream lectures out
there thank you very much for helping me
put my ideas into quick production um
i'll skip this and yeah so obviously
we're out of time hit me up i created a
special slack channel to continue the
conversation there and stop me and
gather fortune
okay thank you so much hey all for being
with us thanks everyone for joining us
unfortunately you don't have time for
questions but you can just post your
questions in the talks channel or you
can just go to the gathering continue
the conversation thank you so much for
being here with us thank you
you